[SQUEAKING]
[RUSTLING]
[CLICKING]
FRANK SCHILBACH: So the quizzes
are not meant to be difficult.
They're mostly meant to provide
some incentives for you to, A,
keep up with the class,
B, to do the reading, C,
to come to class.
Are they actually a
commitment device or not?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: In general, are
the quizzes a commitment device
or not by the
definition that we had?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Why is that?
AUDIENCE: Because
we [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
But I guess one condition
that we have in the commitment
device-- and that's more like
a question of definition--
is like it's chosen by the agent
to actually engage in this,
and I guess you don't
have the choice.
So in some sense,
if I offer to you
to choose quizzes versus not
and you could particularly only
do worse by doing the
quizzes, I could offer you
the choice either you'd
always get 5 on the quizzes,
or you can opt into
saying you do the quizzes,
then you choosing the quizzes
would very much be a commitment
device.
But if I sort of just
impose it on you,
then, strictly
speaking, it is not,
even though it sort of
functions in the exact same way
as if you had chosen it.
OK.
Mostly we are discussing
empirical questions
related to hyperbolic or
quasi-hyperbolic discounting.
I want to have a
short intermezzo
very briefly about
sort of telling you
about how to solve problems with
quasi-hyperbolic discounting
in part because that's
relevant to the problems set.
I already talked
with you briefly
about how do you deal
with fully naive agents
and how do you deal with
fully sophisticated agents.
In some sense, it's fairly
simple in these two cases,
in part because these are
special extreme cases.
Now, the third case
is, what do you
do when you have a partially
naive decision-maker?
And that's a little
trickier, and we
tend to not have
that many problems
related to partially
naive decision-makers.
[INAUDIBLE] is a
little tricky to do.
So essentially, what
you do is you kind of
do the same as you do for
the fully sophisticated
decision-maker.
You do start by doing
backwards induction.
You essentially
solve for what does
the person think they're
going to do in the future.
For that-- I'm speechless.
For that, what do you do is
you use people's beta hat,
and beta hat is essentially
what the person believes
they will do in the future.
And then, essentially, solve
using backwards induction what
the person thinks they will do.
This is the exact
same thing as you
do for a sophisticated
person, except for that you're
using now people's
beta hat as opposed
to people's actual beta.
The difference is, of course,
it's always the beta hat.
It just happens to be for
the sophisticated person
that the beta hat
actually is the beta.
So then, essentially,
you start at the end.
You do backwards induction.
You go back in time,
work yourself [INAUDIBLE]
period two, so then the
person using the beta hat
knows what they're going
to do in the future,
thinks they know what they're
going to do in the future
starting in the next period.
Then you're going to start
solving for the first period,
like what is the person
actually going to do?
For that, what you need is
the person's actual beta
because that's essentially
what determines
people's actual choices.
And then you go
to the next period
and do exactly the same thing.
Again, you do sort of
backwards induction.
You already have solved
that from the previous step.
But then, essentially,
in period two,
then, the person actually
uses again their actual beta
for making their decisions.
So the beta hats are
guiding people's beliefs
about what they think they
will do in the future,
but then you have to
go back and actually
look at what does the
person actually do.
And that often
differs, in particular
when you get to like period two,
three, and four in the future.
Sorry, this is not--
The second thing I
wanted to say is--
and this is mostly relevant
for problem set two.
So far, we have essentially
looked at continuous choices.
It's like going to
a movie versus not,
or at some point you have
like one movie that you can go
to which essentially
is sort of following
the O'Donaghue-Rabin
papers and examples.
You have one problem set you
need to do at some point.
This is essentially
a discrete choice.
Do you do it, or
do you not do it?
Of course, many choices in
life so exactly like that,
like, essentially, when
do you do the problem sets
and so on and so forth,
but other choices in life
are continuous consumption
savings or continuous choices.
It's about like how much do you
eat, how much do you consume,
and so on and so forth.
And sort of the canonical
thing to do in economics
are consumption savings choices.
You have some amount of money.
You think about
how much should you
consume in this period,
how much should you save.
There's an interest rate.
You're going to get more
money than in the future
if you save more and
so on and so forth.
The same principles
here apply as well
except for now you're not
comparing discrete choices,
but now you do, essentially,
[INAUDIBLE] conditions the same
what would you do in
any optimization problem
as you would do in
1401 or one or any sort
of intro micro class where,
essentially, you optimize
using [INAUDIBLE]
conditions, et cetera,
subject to some
budget constraint.
In the recitation, you get
some additional guidance
how to do that, and
particularly, the TAs
will walk you through
a previous problem
from like a few years
ago that essentially
is sort of doing exactly that.
I just want to sort of flag
this so you're not surprised.
This is essentially
sort of 1401 basics
that we discussed in
the first recitation.
There's also some handout
on some refreshers for that,
but that'll come as well.
But the same
principles apply here.
That's exactly the same thing as
we do here in the other choices
that people make
except for now we
have, essentially,
continuous choices.
Any questions on this?
OK.
All right.
So then we're going to talk
about other applications,
starting with credit card teaser
rates or credit card behavior.
This is an old paper
by Ausubel [INAUDIBLE]..
You can have any concerns
about it, but in some sense,
it's sort of nicely illustrates
very simple behaviors
that are very nicely fitting
into the quasi-hyperbolic
discounting model.
So this is evidence from using
real-world credit card usage.
So essentially,
there's a company
who has a bunch of data
on credit card usages,
and as you might be aware,
credit card companies
send out all sorts of
mailers about getting people
to sign up for a credit card.
In particular, once you're
out of school and gainfully
employed, you get
all sorts of mailings
and so on asking you to
sign up for credit cards.
Now, in this particular
example, the company
mailed out randomized
credit card offers
of the following types.
There was like a
standard credit card
offer, which was a 6.9% interest
rate for six months and 16%
afterwards, so there's already,
in some sense, a teaser rate
built-in in the sense
it's starting to be looks
like it's really cheap.
You might sort of think, oh, I'm
going to just bar for a month,
and then eventually,
it gets more expensive.
The hope of the
company, of course,
is that you keep borrowing
from them once it actually
gets more expensive.
And then there's two
randomized conditions.
There's what they call
the teaser deal, which
is 4.9% followed by
16%, and then there's
what they call the
post-teaser deal, which
is 6.9% followed by 4%.
Notice that if you borrow a
given amount for quite a while
and that these two conditions
are pretty much similar,
depending a little bit
how long you borrow,
if you borrow for
something like a year,
then it's about
similar or the same.
If you borrow for
more than a year,
then you know option
three is probably better
than option two for you for a
given amount that you borrow.
But what the company
then has is response rate
and people's 20-month borrowing
history for individuals
who take up the card.
Now, these are kind
of selected, so you
want to be a little bit
careful how to interpret that.
But the response rates
surely are the right thing
to look at because they'd
be randomized across people
who read which letter.
What they find is
that the response rate
is about 2.5 times
larger increase
in take-up in the second
relative to the third group.
Now, given subsequent
borrowing behavior-- and that's
kind of endogenous.
You want to be a little
bit careful with that.
But essentially, if you
look at people's behavior,
the latter is a
much better deal.
So you'd much rather
have-- as I said,
you'd much rather have like
deal number three compared
to deal number two.
And particularly, if you
borrow for, say, two years
like $1,000, you're going
to pay much more interest
in deal number two
compared to number three.
Yes?
Now how do we think about
this from the quasi-hyperbolic
discounting model?
How do we explain this behavior?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] the
one with the [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, exactly.
So let me just
repeat what you said.
So you said, people think they
will not borrow in the future,
or they're like, I'm going
to borrow for a while.
I'm going to borrow
for a few months.
I just need some
money right now.
In the future, surely
I'll be patient.
I'll pay everything back,
and so it doesn't really
matter what the interest
rate is after six months.
Therefore I'm just
going to optimize
according to the six-month
period that I see.
The third deal is
cheaper than the second,
so let me just pick that.
And then so, surprise, people
actually then keep borrowing,
and it ends up being a lot
more expensive than it is.
That's exactly right.
That's what I have here as well.
Now, if people are
sophisticated, why would
they choose option two?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: So
there's sort of the idea
that, essentially, if you
don't like your future self
to borrow, you might want to
actually choose a high interest
rate to protect you
from doing that.
Now, that's a very
sophisticated type of behavior.
My guess is, at
the end of the day,
that will not be
particularly successful
because, at the end of the day,
the 2% difference is probably
not making a huge difference.
But in principle, the data are
sort of consistent with that.
We cannot rule this out.
Now, there's other issues
with like substitution
to other cards and so on,
so you might sort of--
that might backfire
in various other ways,
but in principle, at least,
that's exactly right.
Now, what evidence can
be collect to separate
these stories?
I show you this data from
the paper that they have.
Now, as I'm telling
you, I can't really
disentangle these stories
because there's no other data
available.
But what other data
would you want to know,
would you like to collect
to sort of disentangle
from these two stories or
disentangle these two stories?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Whether people
continued borrowing.
FRANK SCHILBACH: So you could
look at their boring behavior,
and then what would you
conclude, or what data--
what would you--
AUDIENCE: So if they
stopped borrowing,
that would imply they are
sophisticated and they continue
[INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
I think a little
inconclusive in some sense,
but yes, I think that's right.
What else can we collect?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes, exactly.
So if you ask people, what do
you think you're going to do,
that would be helpful.
And then in some
ways, it will also
be nice to have some form of
like demand for commitment.
We don't quite have this
here because neither
of these options is
actually dominated.
You could sort of tell
stories either way.
But once you have
a dominated option,
the naive person would
not pick that anymore.
I think it's also right that
looking at people's borrowing
behavior-- we can also learn
from that in some sense.
It can't be that you keep
doing stuff that's bad for you
if you're really sophisticated.
Sorry.
So two things I think
that you can potentially
collect clearcut evidence
to rule stuff out
is, one, collect beliefs
about for borrowing behavior.
So there's one very nice
paper, a recent paper
by Hunt Allcott, and
Dmitry Taubinsky,
and co-authors that looks
at payday borrowers.
This is like payday lending at
really extremely high interest
rates where people
essentially borrow
against their future
paycheck, and they keep
doing this over and over again.
And what they do there--
they actually elicit
people's beliefs
and say, what do
you think is the
probability that you're
going to borrow again?
You can ask several people
and then, essentially, just
look at what are
the actual beliefs--
sorry, what are the actual
borrowing rates, about what
fraction of people are actually
borrowing again compared
to the perceived fraction.
And what they find, in
fact, is payday borrowers
seem to be quite sophisticated.
So these are people
who actually know,
I'm going to like borrow
again in two weeks from now
and so on, and I'm going to
roll it over and over again.
Now, they also find that that
is more common among repeat
borrowers, so like
somebody who has like
rolled his over five times--
they actually don't have a lot
of illusions of what they're
going to do in the future.
They know they're going
to roll it over again.
When you look at people who are
like first-time or second-time
borrowers, things are different.
There people tend
to think, I'm going
to do this only once
or twice, and then
they sort of surprised
themselves by borrowing again.
That's consistent
with some story
of learning in a sense of they
can't really necessarily nail
that, but I think they
find, essentially,
that or they interpret
their evidence as people do
seem to be learning over time.
They also offer some form
of commitment device.
Essentially, they offer him to
say, if you don't borrow again,
we'll pay you $100
or versions of that.
Or you have to pay or
you can forego money
if you commit to
not borrowing again.
They also find some
evidence of that sort
of suggesting that, again,
these payday borrowers seem
to be quite sophisticated.
Now, of course, it's
a different type
of sample, a different
type of population.
So credit card people,
particularly who
got credit card mailings,
in particular, people
who just started their jobs
and so on and so forth,
might be not as sophisticated.
Now, if you are a credit card
company, what would you do?
How would you react to
that kind of behavior?
Suppose you believed what
I showed you earlier,
the evidence that I just showed
you about from the Ausubel
paper in terms of
people seem to be
either naive or sophisticated
quasi-hyperbolic discounters.
What do you do as a
credit card company?
Whom do you target,
and how do you do it?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: Perhaps you could
map some kind of characteristic
of the person, maybe
demographics like education
or socio-economic
characteristics
with possible
naive/sophisticated
and then almost
price [INAUDIBLE]
target each person based
on those characteristics.
So the sophisticated person
would have the lower teaser
rate and then the higher
interest rate towards the end,
and you could do the same
for those who are naive.
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So what you kind of want
to know in some sense--
you want to know who are
the naive people, who
are the people that we
can essentially exploit
because the naive person
is the person who is going
to be the person who
signs up and then ends up
paying really high interest
rates surprisingly.
So you can
essentially figure out
some ways of making a
lot of money from them.
The exponential discounters or
even the sophisticated people--
they will not be helpful
for you because either they
will, essentially, just
optimize in some sense.
They use some offers.
They get some bonus
points or whatever
for signing up in
the first place
and then essentially
just drop the card
and not use it anymore.
Even a sophisticated
person you can't really
exploit that much
because if you could,
the sophisticated person
would understand that and then
would just not sign
up in the first place.
And this is kind of the answer
to what Lauren just said about,
if somebody if you can make a
lot of money from that person,
it can't be that
person is perfectly
sophisticated because
then, otherwise, the person
would never sign up
in the first place.
Now, credit card
companies-- there's
some evidence, at least,
that credit card companies
do exactly what you just
said, which essentially
is-- so they don't have a
lot of information of people
that they actually mail to.
The one thing that they have
is zip code-level information,
very often about education
and some other characteristics
from some other data sets.
So there's a very
nice paper by Ru
and Antoinette Schoar at
Sloan, at MIT that looks at,
analyzes a detailed data set
of mailed credit card offers.
So essentially,
there are people who
are paid to collect all
the mailings that they
get from different companies,
and just collect them, and have
them analyzed.
And there's sort of a data
set doing exactly that.
And so what they
did is they analyzed
this data set
specifically and looked
at how some of the
details of these offers
relate to things like
education, zip code.
So you look at sort of
education-level data,
like where do the
highly-educated people,
and where do other
people live, and what
they find is that education
levels are systematically
related to things like
backloaded and hidden fees,
teasers, stuff that's
written in small font,
having more photos, color
print, and so on and so forth,
essentially a bunch
of stuff that's
trying to trick people into
things that are bad for them.
So what the credit
card companies
are doing-- they're
essentially sort of saying,
here's some stuff
that is exploiting
potentially naive customers.
Now, you only want to send that
kind of stuff to naive people
or mostly to naive
or less sophisticated
customers, the reason being
that, A, it's costly to do it.
So if you send it to people
who are exponential discounters
or who are more sophisticated,
you're just wasting money,
or they might actually
exploit your offer
by optimizing and getting good
deals out of it in some ways.
So what do you
kind of want to do
is you want to focus
on the naive customers
and sort of exploit
them as much as you can.
Now, actually, it's not that
you want to exploit them
as much as you can.
There are some constraints.
What are the constraints here?
What is a credit card company,
in some ways, worried about?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: They want to make
sure that they can actually
pay the [INAUDIBLE].
FRANK SCHILBACH: Exactly.
So this is a pretty
cynical view of the world,
but I think it's a pretty
correct one in some ways, which
is, the credit card company
wants to exploit people
but only to the extent that
they can actually repay.
The last thing the
credit card company wants
is for people to default, not
because a credit card company
actually cares about the
people who might default
but rather because
the credit card
company has, then,
trouble actually getting
their money back.
So there's,
essentially, some form
of a participation constraint.
And so what Ru and Schoar find
is that, at times-- and maybe
this is suggestive evidence, but
it's pretty neat in some way.
At times when unemployment
insurance from the government
increases, essentially,
as more people have
more money available, a lot
of these fees, et cetera
tend to be higher,
and so one way
to interpret that is,
essentially, there's
a participation constrained
if you want an optimization
problem.
That is to say, they try
to exploit the customers,
but it's subject
to the constraint
that the person
doesn't default or just
doesn't use the offers at all.
Now, that participation
constraint
gets relaxed now that
people, due to unemployment
and other types of insurance,
have more money available,
so essentially, you
can exploit them more.
This is sort of a
pattern, I think,
that's general for many cases.
I think when you, for
example, think about gyms,
you might sort of
say, well, people
choose in gyms the offers
that gyms give to people.
In a way, they are meant
to exploit customers.
Or do you really want what
I showed you last time?
You really want to offer people
these monthly fees or whatever?
Like you want people to
sign up but then actually
not show up very
much to your gym
because you have a
certain capacity.
You'll then hit
your gym capacity.
But some people might
say, well, why not just
ask people to give them
even more and more expensive
contracts that they sign up so
they really sort of-- to screw
them over more and more?
The problem is there's again
a participation constraint.
If the person realizes, I'm
spending way too much money
on this and I'm not
actually going to the gym
ever, that person is
just going to quit.
So you kind of want--
there's this game where,
essentially, you want
your customer to be engaged.
You want your customer to
come back sometimes and feel
good about going to the
gym sometimes and not
feel terrible about
not coming, so that's
why the gyms and other
companies are always
trying to be very motivating.
We choose the best
contract for you.
We're trying to help
you with this and that.
But really, it's, in some
sense, making the appearance
of trying to help the
customers, keeping them happy
while you can exploit
them at the same time.
Now, that's a very
cynical view of the world,
and I'm sure there are some
companies who are actually
care about their customers.
But in some sense,
I think it can
explain quite a few patterns
that we see in the world.
Any questions on this?
Or comments?
OK.
So then next is--
and this is sort of, again,
almost like a classic paper now
because it's from
quite a while ago.
It's a paper by Nava Ashraf and
colleagues in the Philippines.
And these are clients
of a Philippine bank,
and they are randomized
into three different groups
to be receiving three different
kinds of savings product.
The first one is essentially
like a very simple--
sorry.
The first one, number three,
is like a control treatment,
or it's just a standard
savings account.
Here's an account
that you can open,
and you're going to
get some interest rate
for saving in this account.
The second one is like
a marketing treatment
which essentially is
encouraging people to sign up.
Otherwise, it's like
the same, essentially
trying to get people to do it.
Number one-- and
this is, I guess,
the treatment of
interest-- is what's
called the SEED Treatment,
which is encouraging people
to sign up, plus a
commitment offer, which
is clients can restrict
their access to the deposits
upon opening the account.
So what you can essentially
do is you can set some goals.
These goals are either
date-based or amount-based.
So you can say, I want to
save $1,000 or some amount,
and until I've reached that
amount I cannot withdraw any
money.
Alternatively, you
can say, I would
like to save until my
husband's or my wife's
birthday or some other--
child's graduation
and whatever you
want to save for,
Christmas, et cetera,
and only then you can
withdraw the money.
As you can see, most
people seem to be choosing
date-based types of
goals, but others also
have a amount-based.
You can see about 70%
here are date-based,
and 30% are amount-based.
Now, what they
find is, A, there's
quite a bit of take-up
of this account,
and again, when you
think about this,
there's not a good
reason to take up
this account unless you want
to restrict your future self.
So there's some evidence
of demand for commitment.
Second, offering
just kinds of account
increases people's savings, so
on average, people save more.
I'm going to tell
you a little bit
about the distribution of that.
Is actually everybody
better off from doing that?
But on average,
people do save more,
so essentially, it's kind
of similar to the evidence
that I showed you earlier.
Commitment devices,
at least on average,
can improve outcomes or
affect outcomes in some way.
And then number three--
and that's a little
bit suggestive--
but essentially saying, if you
look at money now versus later,
a question that I showed
you earlier in the class,
they actually do predict
commitment take-up consistent
with some form of--
this is really about
time preferences
as opposed to maybe other
things like demand effects,
social-desirability
bias, essentially
customers maybe just wanting to
make the bank happy in some way
because they feel
compelled to do it
because they get some marketing
treatment and a particularly
strong one.
Any questions on this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: No, I
think it's taking it--
I think it's taking it up
and putting some money in it.
Yeah, the take-up
is put in like,
once you put in some money, it's
counted as using or taking up
the account.
Otherwise, it would
be like, yeah,
that's not really anything
now, essentially restricting
your choices in some way
by putting in some money
into this account.
OK.
So next is some work that
I've done in India on alcohol
consumption, and this
is a very common issue
among low-income workers, in
South India, in Tamil Nadu,
and Kerala, and other places.
It's also an issue in other
countries, in Uganda and so on.
So large fractions
of low-income workers
drink large amounts of
alcohol, often daily.
What do I mean by that?
They drink something like five,
six standard drinks per day.
What's a standard drink?
It's like a small beer or like
a shot of liquor, so five,
six standard drinks
are a lot of alcohol.
Now, they also
spend large amounts
of their money of
their income on alcohol
on the order of magnitude
of 20%, 30%, 40%,
so think of these as like
families of five or six.
Sorry, families of
four or five often.
What they earn is something
like 300, 400 rupees per day.
That's usually, often,
the family income.
Some earn a little bit
more, but that's something
like $5, $6, $7 per day.
And often they spend
$1 or $2 on alcohol.
And so when you ask
people, when you ask women,
when you ask men about, how
does alcohol affect your lives,
you get sort of this uniform
response of people saying
like, well, if only
liquor stores closed,
my life would be so much better.
I would love for liquor
prices to be higher,
and I would like to find some
way to reduce my drinking.
But I have trouble doing so.
When you ask people,
OK, now you would
like to reduce your drinking.
It would be great for you the
liquor stores to be closed.
Why is it difficult for you
to reduce your drinking?
The common response is
always, A, addiction,
which makes things
tricky anyway,
but B, people say they
have physical pain,
physical pain from work.
Particularly, these are
people with very low levels
of education, so often
they're illiterate and so on.
So it's very hard for them
to get any job or the like,
so what instead
they have to do is,
essentially, do physical
labor, hard physical labor.
These are like
construction workers,
rickshaw drivers,
sewage workers,
and so on and so forth.
This is really
hard work, and they
tend to have, then, lots of
physical pain from their work.
Now, why is it that, then,
the pain exacerbates,
potentially, people's
self-control problems?
Why is that making things worse?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] you might
have been drinking for instance
social reasons or alcoholism.
Now you're also self-medicating
for [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So what are you
saying, essentially,
is you can do self-medicating
physical pain, in addition
to maybe some other reason,
social reasons and so on.
It turns out, in this setting,
at least, specifically,
people tend to not drink
so much for social reasons.
There's some social function.
There's like funerals or
other sort of festivals where
lots of people
drink, but they're
drinking-- in
particular, in rickshaw
is often people
drink on their own,
essentially to numb
their pain in some ways.
Now, when you think about
self-control problems,
often where self-control
problems arise
is when you have short-run
benefits and long-run costs.
Essentially, that's
sort of the consumption
good that people over consume.
Now, when you think about
physical pain, what does
physical pain do?
It very much increases
the short-run benefits
of drinking while keeping
long-run costs or anything else
constant.
And so if you think about, you
have lots of short-run benefits
now of drinking because there's
lots of pain that alcohol helps
numbing--
and alcohol is a very powerful
anesthetic as it turns out.
So then, essentially,
it sort of increases
the short-run
benefits, and that's
sort of the short-run
desire to drink.
And then any long-run
costs about health
and so on and so forth are
very much in the future,
and that's where, essentially,
the self-control problem
potentially arises.
Now, people not only
drink a lot overall
in Chennai and in
surrounding areas,
but they drink also quite a bit,
in particular rickshaw drivers,
during the day.
So what I was doing there
is essentially just randomly
walking around in Chennai--
our RAs would do that--
walking around in Chennai
and just breathalyzing people
more or less randomly, offering
them, essentially, would
you like to do a breathalyzer
test for some small amount,
regardless of the result.
And about half of these
rickshaw drivers-- and these
are all cycle rickshaws,
so it's not particularly
dangerous to do that.
But about half of them are
showing positive breathalyzer
scores.
So essentially, half of them are
at least somewhat inebriated.
About 20%, 25% are
pretty drunk, as
in their blood alcohol content
is about 0.1 or higher,
which is above the US legal
driving limit overall.
Now, this is during
the regular work hours.
These are people who
are actually at work.
Now, then sort of
seeing that and sort
of having people report about
their self-control problem,
I was then sort
of wondering, OK,
now, what kinds of
commitment devices
could be perhaps offered
to people to reduce
their drinking given
that they tend to report
self-control problems,
or physical pain,
or self-control problems
related to physical pain
are a key issue
and preventing them
from reducing their drinking
if they desire to do so,
of course?
What could we do?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: We could
just tell them
you're going to randomly
administer a breathalyzer test,
and if they haven't been
drinking [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah, so we
could, essentially-- exactly.
So you could essentially say,
I'm going to try and find you.
I'm going to call you
sometimes randomly,
and you get some
reward if you're sober,
so essentially incentivizing
people to be sober.
That's exactly right.
You could do that.
Now, is that a--
so what would be a
commitment device?
What would a commitment
device for that look like?
So what you just
mentioned is essentially
just providing people
incentives, incentivizing them,
and that could truly work.
How would I show that these are,
in fact, self-control problems
or people have quasi-hyperbolic
or similar preferences?
AUDIENCE: So if they choose
to enter into this study,
they're [INAUDIBLE] for
example maybe [INAUDIBLE]
they've been
drinking [INAUDIBLE]..
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
Essentially, you have
to give people choices,
and some choices are
potentially dominating.
So what does that mean?
I'm giving you some choices.
You can choose to either
receive the incentives,
and you only receive these
incentives if you're sober.
Alternatively, I'm going to
just pay you some amount,
and that amount, ideally, is
like higher than the amount
that you could get
from these incentives.
Now, then if you
choose the incentives,
what does that mean?
Essentially, that means
you want to increase
your future prices of drinking.
That would be, essentially,
demand for commitment.
Now, the other thing
we could potentially do
is what I showed
you earlier, which
is the drug that's called
Antabuse which, essentially, is
a drug that you can take to
prevent yourself from being
able to metabolize alcohol.
I was actually thinking
about that for quite a while.
The reason why I wasn't doing
that was the tricky part
here is that, once
you actually start
drinking while you're on this
drug, that's very dangerous.
And particularly if
you have been drinking
for quite a while, withdrawal
symptoms related to alcohol
are very dangerous, so if you
have been drinking alcohol
for 10, 20 years like many of
the people in the sample have,
abruptly reducing your
drinking is dangerous
because you can
essentially get what's
called delirium tremens, very
severe withdrawal symptoms that
could even-- you could
even die from that.
Now, one thing you
could do is when
you get withdrawal symptoms,
you can actually start drinking,
and that helps.
Now, the problem is, when
you have taken Antabuse,
you can't do that.
So essentially,
there's the issues,
and then you get this
alcohol-Antabuse reaction
which is really bad.
So I ended up not doing that
for various ethical and other
reasons.
But what I did do is essentially
give people the option
of dominated choices.
So what does the
experiment look like?
It's a three-week field
experiment with the rickshaw
drivers in Chennai.
We didn't do the random
breathalyzing in the field,
in part because it's really
hard to actually find people
if they're sort of roaming
around on their rickshaw.
Not everybody has
their phone, or answers
their phone, and so on.
So instead, we
asked people to come
to the study office between
6:00 and 10:00 PM every day.
It's between 6:00 and 10:00 PM
because breathalyzer tests can
tell you about drinking during
the previous something like six
to 10 hours, so if you
breathalyze me now,
what you can tell
is what I have been
drinking in the last, let's
say, eight hours or something.
You cannot really tell whether
I have been drinking yesterday.
So if we did the breathalyzer
test in the morning,
that would not be particularly
helpful because, really, it
can't tell you very
much about the drinking
on the previous day.
And then we provided financial
incentives for sobriety
for a subset of individuals.
What do these financial
incentives look like?
They look very
simple and something
very similar to what
you just suggested.
So option A-- these are
the financial incentives--
are people are given 60
rupees, which is about $1, just
for showing up.
So just come to the
office, and show up.
Do a breathalyzer test, and
do some survey questions.
And you get like
$1 for doing that.
And then if your
breathalyzer score is 0,
you get another
dollar, 120 rupees.
That's essentially the
incentives for sobriety.
Now, option B-- and people
were given choices for that.
Option B was-- there was
like three different versions
of that.
The first one is where option
B was 90 rupees, which,
essentially, is,
come to the office,
and you can choose
to get 90 rupees.
Just come to the office.
Whenever you show up, you
get 90 rupees, regardless
of what your
breathalyzer score is.
You are breathalyzed, but
it doesn't matter what
your scores for your payment.
Now, when you choose the
incentives over option B,
is that a commitment
device, or how
do we think about this choice?
What do we learn
from that choice?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Why?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
So let me give you
an example of a person
who might choose this.
Suppose there's a person who
is actually mostly sober,
is an exponential
discounter, and wants
to be drunk just once a week.
So-- sorry-- these are
choices for six days
for like the following week.
So the person is
perfectly rational.
The person has perfect
foresight and knows
that they're going to
be drunk once next week,
and they're going to choose
option A because they
think it's a great deal.
And so they actually
don't want any commitment.
The only reason why
they choose that is
because the expected value of
the money that they will get
will be higher if they are, at
least half of the time, sober.
So that choice, in fact,
is not a commitment device.
However, moving towards
choices two and three,
now we get into territory
of dominated contracts
that, in fact, are
commitment devices.
So the key part
here is that, when
you look at the second
choice, when you choose, now,
option A over option B, you
can actually only do worse.
The only reason why
you choose option A
is because you want
to have incentives.
Now, you risk showing up drunk
on some days, in which case
you get less money,
but the benefit of that
now is that then now you
have these incentives.
So essentially, you
want incentives,
but what you take into
account is that, potentially,
if you don't show up
sober all the time,
you might lose some money.
So this kind of contract
or this type of choice
we cal a weekly-dominated
contract or choice
in terms of steady payments.
So if people choose option
A and the second choice,
that is some demand
for commitment.
Now, when I look at
the third choice,
now option A is
strictly-dominated.
So now, if you choose option
A, you will do worse for sure
in terms of how much
you will be paid.
Every day, you got like 30
rupees, which is about 10%
of people's daily incomes.
Every day, you got
30 rupees less,
and the benefit, again, is
like incentives for sobriety.
So if you want to choose
these incentives that will
be costly for you for sure--
and now you have a sort of weigh
whether you like those or not.
So what I find is
and what you see here
is, essentially, the fraction
of people choosing incentives
for choice one, two, and three.
So in black you see choice one,
which is a 90 rupees choice.
In dark blue you see
the 120 rupees choices.
You see the
weekly-dominated choices,
and then you see, in light
blue, the 150 rupee choices.
These are the
strictly-dominated choices,
and there's like three weeks.
And people will do this.
So each week, they choose
for the following week
what incentives they would
like to set themselves
for the next six days.
So these are the
three options again,
and you see the
choices over time.
So what we find is or
what I find is that,
in fact, quite a few people,
about half of the individuals,
choose the incentives when
they're weekly-dominated,
which have some evidence
of demand for commitment,
but perhaps more strikingly,
about a third of individuals
choose the incentives when
they're strictly-dominated.
So these are people who are
willing to forgo three times
in a row, not just once
but in the second week
and also in the third
week, and then if anything,
the fraction of people
choosing these incentives
goes up over time.
People are willing to
choose these incentives
and willing to give up about
10% of their daily incomes
for like an entire week to
receive incentives to be sober.
So that's very strong evidence
of demand for commitment.
Now, what we also find is,
when you sort of randomize
just the incentives
themselves for some people
versus unconditional
payments overall,
these incentives are,
in fact, successful
in reducing people's
day drinking.
So people actually
show up more sober
when they receive incentives.
However, as you might
have expected as well,
the problem is the
breathalyzer incentivizes
during the day, the time
before 6:00 and 10:00
PM, before people come
to the study office.
It is not incentivizing the time
after that's in the evening.
And as you sort of--
this is some work by--
Holmstrom and others would
say, if you have multitasking
at different times of the
day or different actions
that you can take, if you
incentivize one thing, what
often happens-- people
follow these incentives,
but then they substitute to
other things in their life.
So then what, in fact, happens--
overall, people's
overall drinking
does not decrease very much.
So while people seem to
have quite a bit of demand
for these incentives,
in fact, it
is helpful for increasing
their daytime sobriety
but not helpful for decreasing
their overall drinking.
So then I was
looking at the impact
of that treatment in the
sense like, now people
are more sober during the day.
In fact, somewhat
surprisingly, I
find very little evidence
on labor market outcomes.
It's not like actually
people are working better,
but I do find people make
different savings decisions.
People are willing to save a
lot more when they're sober,
even when you take into
account that they also
might have more money overall,
or at least more money
available.
Yes?
AUDIENCE: I was wondering
if there was [INAUDIBLE]
but they may drink at night
FRANK SCHILBACH: So I
spent quite a bit of time
thinking about demand effect and
making sure that people are--
some of the people
in the setting
have much less concerns
about what other people think
when they drink.
They're very happy to tell you,
yesterday I drank six drinks.
They're also very happy
to tell you, yesterday I
spent a third of my income
on alcohol and so on.
People are very open about
this, so it's not like people
misreport in surveys and so on.
People's reported drinking
is also very much consistent
with the actual
breathalyzer scores,
so if you sort of
matched that up
in terms of how much have
you been drinking today
versus what the
breathalyzer score says,
that seems consistent as well.
Now, there are some
studies looking
at social-desirability
bias and demand effects,
and often what you find is
that when choices are not
incentivized, when they
are very weak incentives,
there is often evidence
for demand effect
and social-desirability bias.
But when you make things very
costly in a sense of like,
this is a very
costly thing for you
to do to just make the
experimenter happy--
we spent a lot of
time essentially
being very clear about like,
you can do whatever you want
and so on and so forth.
And what we tend to find is
that, in the first few days,
people seem slightly
uncomfortable in this.
There's more to the
study, but there's
like a baseline period
of about a week,
and the first few
days, people seem
to be slightly uncomfortable
of being drunk in the office
and so on and so
forth and sort of
having positive
breathalyzer scores.
That goes away very
quickly, so people
are very happy to show
up as drunk as they are.
So overall, I would think,
if this is one choice,
and you're like, maybe
people are making mistakes,
or people maybe want
to make you happy,
once you make that choice
once, for a whole week
you get, essentially,
a lot less money
than you would get otherwise.
You make that choice again.
Again, you get, like
for a whole week a lot
less money than you
would otherwise,
and then people
choose it yet again.
So while I can't entirely
rule out this explanation--
there's a discussion
of that in the paper.
While I can't rule
out this entirely,
it seems unlikely, at least in
the second and third choice,
given that it's really,
really costly for people.
AUDIENCE: My question
was also related.
If they know that the
[INAUDIBLE] device is not
working because they
are drinking at night,
why do they keep--
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So the second
question is like, OK,
now why are people
making these choices?
So one broad question
is like, OK, so--
when talking to people, a lot
of people would say, well--
they would come, be like, last
week it was really difficult.
I didn't really
succeed and so on.
And then they would be
like, from tomorrow onwards,
things will be different.
So there is lots of
people who, in fact, seem
naive in the sense
of they really think,
going forward, they will
change their behavior.
Often, I think what
they are reasonably
clear about is how
often they will actually
be sober going forward.
What they have trouble
with is, essentially,
predicting their behavior
later in the day.
So they seem to think
like, OK, tomorrow
I'm not going to drink,
and then I'm also
not going to drink at nights.
That doesn't seem to change.
Now, there's a
second explanation
that's also in the paper
and discussed in more detail
that I can't really
necessarily rule out.
There are actually some benefits
of reducing people's drinking.
These are all kind
of small benefits,
but they actually
sort of add up.
So one part of that is savings.
People save a lot more money.
They get more
interest from saving.
That's actually quite a bit of
money that they make from that,
so they potentially
make better decisions.
Second, they have like-- so
while it's not significant,
people have somewhat
higher earnings.
People also have
somewhat reduced
costs of drinking and so on.
So there's some,
essentially, evidence
of several benefits in the
order of magnitude of like 5,
10 rupees per day.
So when you have somewhat
increased earnings,
somewhat reduce expenditures
on alcohol, increased savings--
and then on top of
that, people would also
tell you they like to be what
they say, like a sober man.
These are all men.
They like to be a sober man,
and so they have some value of,
actually, sobriety
during the day.
So I think it's a mixture.
My guess is-- when we've had
to best explain the evidence
that we have, it's a
mixture of there actually
being some evidence of benefits
of being sober that you
can weigh against like 30
rupees forgone benefits
from the study.
And there is also some naivete
in a sense of people desires,
people's beliefs about
wanting to drink glass also
in the evening, and that's just
not necessarily working out.
I want to say another
comment to this,
which is when you see
people choosing commitment
devices that fail, you
can't necessarily rule out
that people are
reasonably sophisticated,
the reason being--
for example, if I
were a smoker that
smoked a lot and the value
of me stopping to smoke
is really high-- suppose I think
if I just could stop smoking
I would live like
five years longer.
That's a huge value in
terms of the benefits.
If somebody came to
me and said, there's
a commitment device with a
1% chance it's going to work.
Would you like to buy it?
And it costs $100.
I might actually choose
this commitment device
because the expected
value of that
is actually higher, even
if 99% of the cases I'm
actually going to fail.
So then you're
looking at the data.
You might say, look, these
people are essentially
making a bunch of mistakes.
But I think from
their perspective
it's rather-- they have
been drinking for so long.
They struggle with
this, and they
try to reduce their drinking.
There is a chance that
maybe this will work.
Maybe it will not.
So let me really try
and do this and see.
Unfortunately, as it turns out,
it's, in fact, not successful,
at least when it comes to
their drinking overall.
Second, speaking of
smoking, as a second paper
on commitment devices related
to sort of addictive products,
this is a voluntary commitment
product for smoking cessation.
Smokers are offered a
nonstandard savings account.
This is the same setting
as in the Philippines
where these are
clients of a bank.
These are smokers selecting
on actually somebody
being a smoker.
And they are offered the
following commitment device.
You can deposit
funds for six months,
and then you can take a urine
test for nicotine and cotinine,
which apparently tests pretty
well, whether you haven't been
drinking-- sorry, not been
smoking for the last week
or so or a bit longer.
If you pass, you get the money
back that's in your account.
If you fail, the money
is gone, essentially.
Now, do we think this is a
good commitment contract?
Or do we like this or not?
Or how do we think about
this commitment contract?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yeah.
Exactly, you could lose
quite a bit of money
and make people quite
unhappy, but do we think--
actually, suppose you
were sophisticated.
Would you sign up, or
how would you behave?
Like suppose I offer
you the contract.
You have it now.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Right.
So you put money in it, but
I think the one key part here
is that the actual
quitting only occurs
in like six months from now.
It's to say, it's sort of a
little bit of a funny thing
in the sense of saying,
look, you really
want to quit smoking.
It's like, in six
months from now,
you already have lots of
long-run benefits-- sorry,
lots of long-run
costs of smoking,
which is lung cancer, health
issues, and so on and so forth.
Now I'm sort of adding
long-run incentives
in like six months from now,
which is a little bit far away.
So what it sort of needs is--
in a way, you would not start
quitting to smoke right away.
You would say, well, in
five months from now,
I can sort of stop.
And now, of course, you can
then build your own commitment
device by putting
in a lot of money
and then really ramping
up these incentives.
But in some sense, what you kind
of want is a commitment device
that--
I sign up for it.
I'm like really excited
to stop smoking,
and now you want to provide
incentives almost right away
to get people going.
But instead, it's this
commitment device that
requires quite a bit of
sophistication, in a sense,
of saying, now, I know that
in like six months from now
I want to stop smoking.
I kind of don't want to
stop smoking right now.
I can always do it tomorrow,
because people like to delay,
depending on how naive
they are and so on.
And so I can see lots
of people then saying,
yeah, in three months from
now I'm going to do it.
And then they're going to
put in some money and so on,
but they end up not
doing it eventually.
It turns out, empirically,
it works reasonably well
in a sense.
There's like 10% of take-up.
Like 10% of people
actually put in some money.
There is also like an impact on
smoking of 3 percentage points.
That sounds kind of
small, but that's actually
pretty sizable in
terms of getting people
to stop smoking is pretty hard.
Also, these effects
persist in surprise tests
like 12 months later.
So when you sort of surprise
people later and sort of say,
hey, surprise,
here's a test, you
get some money for
doing it, turns out
that people who offered this
commitment, smoking a contract
or product are, in fact,
less likely to smoke.
Now, a second question
related to that is to say,
if people are unhappy about
their smoking in the future,
if people would like to
reduce their future smoking,
there's some
arguments that taxes
can be some form of not
quite commitment devices
but ways in which you
could reduce your smoking.
So the rickshaw drivers in
Chennai would of tell me,
I would love for
alcohol prices to be
more expensive
because that would
help me reduce my drinking.
So if they could set prices,
quite a few people would say,
I would set prices really
high, so that would
help me reduce my drinking.
So if people could
choose their own prices
and if they would set high
prices, that would be,
essentially, a form
of a commitment
device to reduce your
smoking or drinking.
So when you look
at smokers, there's
lots of people who say
they would like to quit.
About eight out of 10
US smokers say that.
If you have friends
who smoke, you
will get this common patterns.
So lots of people say,
I would love to quit,
lots of quit attempts that
often are not successful.
Now, one way you can
sort of reduce smoking
potentially or accomplish
your goal is to say,
prices might be higher.
Again, higher
prices-- essentially,
that's the law of demand.
Like if prices go up,
people smoke less,
and that's true for
smoking, drinking as well.
And so that might help curb
people's self-control problems.
Now, one simple question
that John Gruber, who
was in the economics department,
and Sendhil Mullainathan we're
asking is like, well,
once we increase taxes,
now smokers are
actually happier.
And so if it's true that people
have self-control problems,
people might be happier because
it helps them, essentially,
reduce their smoking.
It helps them deal with
their self-control problems.
You could even say, once prices
become infinitely expensive,
as long as people can't
substitute in certain ways
or get around these
rules, they might even
be happy about banning
smoking because that would
be the simplest way of getting
rid of their smoking habit
if they really want to do so.
Now, Gruber and Mullainathan
have an empirical test
of this in the US and
Canada, and in fact,
when you look at
variation over time,
higher cigarette
taxes are associated
with higher
self-reported well-being,
in particular among those
who are likely smokers.
Now, you could also say,
well, other people are happier
as well, but that's not that
interesting because there's
externalities from smoking.
And if you are not
a smoker, you should
be happy about smoking
taxes because, A, they're
going to reduce
your externalities.
People are going to
smoke less in your face,
and you might sort of like that.
Second, there's going to
be revenues from taxation.
You're also going to be very
happy if other people pay
higher taxes.
But what they do
is they look at,
essentially,
households particularly
that are likely smokers, and
that helps then identify--
or that's much more interesting
a result than households
who are non-smokers.
There's some caveat that
some of the respondents
might be spouses of
the actual smokers.
Again, that's, in
some sense, less
interesting from the
beta-delta perspective
because if the husband or
wife wants to get their spouse
to smoke less, they might
be quite happy about it,
but it's more like because the
spouse thinks their husband
or wife have a self-control
problem as opposed to they
have one themselves.
Or it could be even-- like for
lack of self-control problems,
it could just be the
husband likes smoking,
the wife does not.
If prices go up, the husband
might still smoke less,
and the wife might be happier
or the other way around
and nothing to do with
self-control problem.
Just like if prices go up
people, consume stuff less.
To be clear, such
effects are not
possible and not consistent
with exponential discounting
because if you're an
exponential discounter,
you would either smoke
because you like smoking
or you would not smoke.
There's no scenario in
which you are smoking
but you really
would like to quit.
If you would like to quit and
if it's worth for you to quit,
you would actually do
that, so you would not
be happier about higher
prices the same way
as you would not be happy
about higher prices for apples
and bananas.
People don't like high prices
because, essentially, they
have to pay more, and that
sort of reduces their budget.
Any questions on this?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
FRANK SCHILBACH: Yes.
So I think you're bringing up a
very good point, which is often
a big discussion for
so-called "sin taxes," which
is essentially taxes on
either cigarettes, on alcohol,
on sodas, and so on.
So there's different
objectives often.
One is essentially helping
people who potentially
have self-control problems.
Second, there is sort of
redistribution as a goal
or a problem in some sense.
And that's the same case
in India, in some sense.
If you increased the alcohol
prices in India, on the one
hand, people would drink less,
but the elasticity of drinking
tends to be fairly low,
meaning that if you increase
the price of alcohol, or
cigarettes, or the like by 1%,
usually the consumption only
reduces by less than 1%,
which means that overall
expenditures-- while people
actually drink or smoke less,
overall expenditures actually
go up.
And so if you're
worried about the poor,
then, in particular,
A, they tend
to consume these
types of goods more
when it comes to smoking,
drinking, but also sodas,
in particular in the US--
when you're worried, then,
about increasing taxes and then
expenditures and
then, essentially,
having a particular high
burden among the poor--
So then there's questions
on how to deal with that.
So one potential "why did you do
this" would be, in some sense,
to refund, then, the
taxes that are actually
incurred, in particular, then
in some form of transfers.
That's often not
necessarily feasible,
but that's exactly the
problem when you think
about, for example, soda taxes.
There's a very nice paper
by Dmitry Taubinsky,
and Hunt Allcott, and so on--
I can add this to the slides--
that essentially looking
at exactly that in the US.
When you think about
soda taxes, how
do you deal with two
different objectives?
One is helping people to consume
less sodas if they desire
to do so and second,
redistribution
dealing with the
fact that the burden
is particularly high
among the poor in terms
of how much money to pay.
You kind of want it
to be the opposite.
You want the rich to pay more
taxes rather than the poor,
and some of these
taxes do the opposite.
And then there's
a question of, how
do you weigh these
two objectives,
and how you can maybe
undo some of the effects
that you're doing?
Yes?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: I
think these are simple--
these are just simple surveys
about people's happiness
and so on and so forth.
Is that your question?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]?
FRANK SCHILBACH: Oh,
I think this is just
trying to predict it
using the demographics.
So I think one of the key--
the key weakness of the
study is two things.
They just do not
have data on like,
does the respondent actually
smoke, so they only know,
essentially, household
characteristics, how
rich are they are,
and so on and so forth
from, essentially, a
bunch of survey questions.
But there's no actual question
of, do you smoke or not?
And so that's why,
in part, this paper,
in fact, is not published
in a top journal, the reason
being that exactly
that's the issue.
A, you don't actually know
whether the person smokes.
B, it could be that it's a
spouse of a smoker that's
answering the question.
So we kind of know that the
propensity of that household
to smoke from other data sets
when we try to just predict
smoking using these
demographics is high,
but we don't actually
know in the specific cases
are people smoking,
which makes it
sort of vulnerable to these
kinds of concerns, yeah.
OK.
Let me talk briefly
about a fertilizer
and then summarize a little
bit the evidence that we saw.
So this is a paper by Esther
Duflo and Michael Kremer,
who recently won a Nobel
Prize in economics.
Esther Duflo is in the Economics
Department at MIT as well,
and Michael Kremer
is at Harvard.
It's a paper with John
Robinson from 2011 in the AR.
What this paper looks
at is fertilizer
used in Western
Kenya, and this is
one of these technologies
in developing countries
where there's quite
a bit of evidence,
and people think the returns
to using fertilizer are high.
That's a thing that
farmers could use.
Essentially, it would
increase your yields.
The returns are on the order
of magnitude of like 50%,
100% often over the course
of like a few months.
So it's a really highly
profitable type of investment.
It's also like a
divisible investment.
It's not like a cow, or
like a tractor, or something
where you have to save a lot
of money to actually buy it.
This is a thing where you
can buy like a kilo or 5
kilos of fertilizer.
You can lose very small amounts
of money and then start saving.
And if the returns
are really that high,
people are just using it and
then become richer over time.
Now, there's a
persistent finding
that fertilizer
use, in particular
in sub-Saharan Africa,
tends to be low,
including in Western Kenya
and the area of this study.
Now, one explanation
that people often say
is that farmers would like
to purchase fertilizer.
When you ask them around
the time of harvest,
which is when they
have a lot of money--
so there are these
harvest cycles.
Farmers farm maize in this area.
When you ask them around
the time of harvest
when people have lots of money
and ask them about their plans
to purchase fertilizer,
they would say, oh, yeah,
I'd love to put this
fertilizer, it's great,
and so on and so forth.
But then lots of stuff comes up.
Lots of expenses
pile up, school fees,
and friends ask for
money, and other festivals
and so on and so forth.
So then when the actual
new season comes,
when the planting time
or the top dressing time
comes when the maize
is a little bit higher
and you're supposed to add
fertilizer to your maize,
then people don't
have any money left.
Now, one way to
overcome this issue
was-- essentially, the best kind
of commitment and some sense
is to just do the thing
that you're planning to do,
and that's exactly what they're
doing in this experiment.
So what they're doing is they
vary the timing of the purchase
decision and offer people
time-limited discounts
around the time of harvest.
So around the time of harvest,
they give a very small discount
and say, you can
essentially buy fertilizer,
and that's going to
be delivered to you
around the time of harvest.
But you have to
buy it right now.
And they get these different
forms of discounts,
but essentially, the
discounts tend to be small.
And the key part here
is that these discounts
are time-limited,
as in like it's only
around the time of harvest, so
you can only do it right now.
You cannot procrastinate it in
any way and say, oh, next week,
or in two weeks, or three weeks
from now, I'm going to do it.
And so that's essentially
a form of a commitment
device in the sense
of, in some ways,
the best commitment device
of, when you want something
to get done, you can just
do it, and then you're
essentially done.
So people do these early
purchases of fertilizer,
and nobody resells
it or the like.
That's just not a
thing people do.
In principle, they
could obviously do that,
but that tends to
be not the case.
And what they find,
in a sense-- they
find very large effects of
this type of commitment device
or the early purchase option.
Even when the discount is
very small, very minor-- often
it's just like delivery
to people's homes
from the fertilizer store,
which is not very hard to do.
So even when this discount
is relatively small,
there's large effects on
people fertilizer use.
And the effects are much larger
than like offering people
discounts around the
time of planting.
So they have another
condition where
they say, around the
time of planting,
when the time comes to
actually use fertilizer,
they have a 50% discount
around that time.
But essentially,
that discount almost
does nothing, the
reason being that, when
people have run out
of money, it doesn't
matter what the price is.
You can't buy any fertilizer
because you're cash-constrained
and can't buy it.
Now, that's a very interesting
finding, in part for policy,
because there's also
quite a bit of concerns
about over-adoption, about
fertilizer subsidies being
very expensive, and
so on and so forth.
And now, when you provide
time-limited discounts
around the time of harvest
that are very small,
you can potentially,
essentially,
not spend a lot of money,
have large increases
in fertilizer use
among the people
who have self-control
problems, among the people who
would actually like
to use fertilizer.
If instead you provide discounts
around the time of planting
of 50% or higher, A, that's
really expensive to do,
and governments, in particular
in Kenya or sub-Saharan Africa
in general, tend to not
have a lot of money.
So it's a very
expensive thing to do.
Plus, you're also distorting
a lot of decisions
among exponential discounters.
What you're doing is,
now I'm giving you--
I'm making fertilizer
much cheaper for you.
If you don't have a
self-control problem
to start with, you're going to
overuse fertilizer because now,
essentially, fertilizer is like
artificially cheap for you,
essentially.
So you push some people
to overuse fertilizer
using an actual discount
around the time of planting.
Instead, what this policy
does-- essentially,
it gives very small discounts
that are very cheap,
and it mostly affects people
with self-control problems.
Those are the people
who, essentially,
would procrastinate
buying fertilizer.
They buy it right now.
They don't spend a
lot of money on it,
and you could have potentially
large effects, as they
have shown in this paper.
Any questions on this?
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Did they
do a part where
they show that farmers
become more sophisticated?
FRANK SCHILBACH:
No, they do not.
They have, essentially,
one-shot decisions for farmers,
and they sort of have some
effects over the course
of several seasons.
But it's essentially not
the same choices and so on.
So this is, in some sense, an
early paper that doesn't quite
look into that.
Some of their work on
sophistication and naivete
comes a little later.
So let me briefly summarize and
talk a little bit about people
feeling when it comes to
using commitment devices.
So I've shown you
several examples
and there are quite
a few more examples
of demand for commitment in
different research studies.
These are all research
studies that people
have done one way or the other.
Often, there's a
significant share
of people who demand commitment
one way or the other.
That's [INAUDIBLE] there's a
significant share of people
who struggle with self-control
problems in some way,
and they also are at least
partially sophisticated
because they sort of understand
it and demand commitment.
Now, there's also like a very
high variation in the fraction
of people demanding commitment.
In some places, it's very
high, as I showed you
in the alcohol examples
and in some other examples
that I haven't
necessarily shown you.
In other examples, like, for
example, in the smoking example
and so on, the demand for
commitment tends to be,
actually, quite low.
So why is that?
Well, we don't actually
know necessarily.
There's a few explanations
that people have.
One of them is uncertainty.
People might be really
worried about the risk.
So if you have lots of
uncertainty in your life,
if you don't know
whether next month you're
going to be smoking or not, or
you might have a really-- you
might have a really
stressful month next month
and you don't probably
know whether that's
going be stressful
or not, you might not
want to choose a commitment
device because it's
very costly for
you, potentially,
because you might start
smoking again or do
other things for reasons that
are not necessarily related
to self-control.
It's just out of your control.
Similarly, for example,
in the data entry example
that I showed you,
people might not
choose to have a positive
target because they're really
worried about risk,
and in particular,
one characteristic
that was very much
predictive of whether people
choose these commitment
devices, whether
they have kids--
the reason being that the kids--
they might be sick.
They might have really bad
nights and so on and so forth,
and so that's an
increase-- that's
the risk of data entry
productivity in the future.
So one part is uncertainty.
A second part is naivete.
Partial naivete can get people
to not purchase or demand
certain commitment devices,
and naivete might vary it
quite a bit across settings.
It might be that
you might just be
like a first-time customer
or a first-time user
of either payday
loans or of drinking,
and smoking, and so on.
You might be quite naive.
In contrast, in my
setting in Chennai
when I looked at
drinkers, there people
have been drinking
for many, many years.
In some sense, they're not as
naive about their drinking,
at least overall.
Another aspect is experience
with commitment devices,
and this is what your
question was about.
Like when you provide
people commitment devices,
maybe it requires some
learning over time.
And again, if you look
at different settings,
people have different
types of experience.
Overall, we don't know the
answer to these questions.
In a sense, we don't
actually know exactly what's
going on why is demand
for commitment quite
different across settings.
A second question that we don't
really know is like, well,
so there are these
research studies
that look at commitment
device and say, OK,
commitment devices,
at least in theory,
should help some people.
But we see actually very
few real-world examples
that actually help.
Yesterday, you
mentioned some of them
that seem to be at least
helpful for some of you.
By the way, if you
would email me those,
I'd like to collect
them and report back
to David Laibson who says
uncertainty is the issue.
But we don't have it really
figured out in some sense.
If commitment devices
were really that great,
you would think that it
really would take off.
There would be a company
that would really make
a lot of money with using them.
There are some companies
that we see in the world,
but it's not really--
it can't really
say it has really
fully taken off,
perhaps some companies
related to cell phone
usage, or computer
usage, and so on,
but it's not as prevalent and
widely used as we might expect,
given the theory
literature that we have.
Now, one important
part that's really
another potential contributor
to [INAUDIBLE] demand
for commitment is that
people might not only
be naive in a sense that
they might not understand
the value of commitment devices
and then that might prevent
them from taking them up,
but even conditional demand
commitments they might fail.
And there's a couple
of examples here.
For example, in the Philippines
savings accounts example
that I showed you, the SEED
commitment savings account--
and John has a very nice
paper that shows that.
In fact, when you look
at the same setting,
a similar experiment, offering
people this commitment contract
has positive effects
on people's savings.
So people do actually
save more on average
compared to a control group.
However, there's also
a pretty large fraction
of people who fail in
reaching their goals,
and then often they have to pay
some penalty for doing that.
Now, that's really bad
marketing for your product.
If you think about
selling this product,
if half of your customers
are really unhappy about it,
that's going to be
very tricky to do.
So there's lots of questions
about how to best design
commitment devices, how
can we perhaps target
customers who might not fail and
perhaps design them differently
for different people, but
we haven't necessarily
figured out how to do that.
Liang Bai and Gautam
Rao and co-authors
have a similar example of
a health commitment product
in India where,
essentially, they're
trying to incentivize people to
go to hypertension doctor visit
to get checkups for
their hypertension.
Lots of people say
they would like to go
and so on and so forth.
You offer them
commitment devices
to essentially provide
themselves incentives to go.
Pretty few people actually
sign up in the first place,
which is also consistent
with some form of naivete
and so on and so forth, but even
among the people who sign up,
lots of people actually fail.
So you end up having people
who essentially set themselves
incentives to go to the doctor.
They're willing to pay
for going in the future
or setting themselves
incentives to go
to the doctor in the
future, and then they
have these incentives.
And then the incentives are
actually not successful,
and they end up not going.
Again, that's very
much consistent
with naivete or at
least partial naivete
or partial sophistication.
And there's many
questions now about,
if that's the case, how do
we design better commitment
devices that work
for more people that
are more successful for
people, and how do we
avoid that some people
sign up for them when they,
in fact, are doing worse
because, again, that's really
bad marketing for your product.
And of course, it's bad for
the people who are doing worse.
They would be, essentially,
better off if they had never
been offered this
device, at least ex post.
Any questions on this?
So then, very briefly,
there's a second view
that you might have is to say,
well, maybe commitment devices
are just not that helpful.
In some sense, we have not
figured out how to do this.
Companies have had lots of
time to figure this out.
Researchers have
not figured this out
in a sense of
like-- well, we have
lots of evidence of
demand for commitment
in terms of people wanting
commitment devices.
We have, actually, not that much
evidence of commitment devices
being useful in the real world
in the sense of persistently
showing that they
make things better.
There are some
examples, to be clear.
For example, the
data entry example
does show that people are
more productive at work,
and probably employers
should do that.
But another view
would be like, well,
if commitment devices
are not really helping--
so think of commitment devices
as a way of providing people
some choice options for given
self-control problems or given
naivete.
Now, there's different
things you could do.
You could do some
things in terms
of trying to address
people's naivete,
and the problems ask you a
little bit to think about that.
How do you actually
get people to be
less naive if that depresses
demand for commitment?
Another way to say is you
could try to essentially try
to reduce people's
present bias or get
at the sources of people's
present bias overall.
There's different
ways, and we have only
started thinking
about or coming up
with some potential
explanations,
but for example, a paper
that we have on sleep
finds that when
people are napping
in the afternoon, which some
of you do also in my class--
that reduces your present bias
and [INAUDIBLE] task and also
savings.
So that's to say, perhaps sleep,
perhaps alcohol consumption,
perhaps other sort
of factors might
affect people's present bias,
so if you could understand
these underlying factors and
if you could tackle them,
that would be another way of
getting around, potentially,
self-control problems
causing trouble
by getting at the root
of this particular issue
if you think that's
an issue overall.
There's some other research
that I find quite interesting,
which is the idea that present
bias is very much related
to attention in the
sense that people
pay too much attention to the
present compared to the future.
So now, if you could
sort make the future more
salient in certain ways, if you
could make people think more
about the future, how
things will be like,
they might behave
more patiently.
So Hal Hershfield has
a series of papers,
and Hal Hershfield is the guy on
the left, the picture that you
see, who used computer software
to make people look older.
So on the right
of the screen, you
see Hal Hershfield like another
40 years old or something,
and so what they did is
they tried to show people,
essentially, pictures
of their old ourselves.
And this is how you're going
to look like in 40, 50 years
from now, and then
think about how
things might be like
in terms of your health
and so on and so forth.
And then get people to
make savings choices.
And there's some
evidence, at least,
that increasing people's focus
and attention to the future
might actually make
them more patient,
and there's quite a
bit of work of people
trying to do that right now.
So just to give you
a brief summary--
I think I said already almost
everything that's to be said--
exponential discounting
is like a workhorse model
of modern economics.
It's extremely important.
And just to be clear, it's
helpful for many applications,
and it's been a very
successful model.
There's some limitations and
some things that we cannot
explain, so quasi-hyperbolic
discounting or some forms
of different discounting
models might be able to improve
the predictability
of our models.
Commitment devices,
in particular,
may help improve outcomes,
but we haven't quite
figured out how to
make them actually
most useful for the world.
There's lots of research
going on in this area.
Next week, we're going to
talk about risk preferences.
In particular, I'd like
you to read the paper
by Rabin and Thaler, 2001.
In recitation this
week, there will be more
on time preferences,
in particular related
to the next problem
set, and then
sort of an introduction
to risk preferences.
If you don't remember
what risk preferences are,
you should very much come
to recitation and get
a refresher of that.
Thank you very much.